there's more to Discovery's naked and
afraid' than people running around in
the buff trying to start fires by
rubbing sticks together a lot of
planning goes into it as well as some
dirty deeds behind the scenes here's the
naked truth about naked and afraid'
truth or fiction lo and behold another
reality show that's received allegations
of fakery controversial contestant Anora
bowen outed naked and afraid' in a blog
post in late 2015 in her post she
recalls that producers made sure they
didn't miss out on exploiting her
father's death in between frequent
interviews about his passing she was
also told by producers to refer to a
regular magnifying glass she's brought
as her father's magnifying glass her
main complaints stemmed from the fact
that she was just trying to survive
while the show was scripting her a fake
story and coaching her on how to act at
the same time which can be pretty
distracting doctors without lockers in
the same blog post an aura bowen also
relates that while out on a walk one day
she stumbled upon the production
company's medical tent so of course upon
discovering it she rummaged through it
and found some emergency which she took
and shared with contestants and she's
not the only one with sticky fingers
according to Bowen during filming for
naked and afraid XL fellow contestants
stole food from the medics and for
revealing the truth to the world bowen
received the honor of being threatened
with a lawsuit ah show business real
danger despite the allegations of
artificiality against the show the
people who appear on naked and afraid
really do face actual dangers but some
of the dangers get toned down for TV
during the very first episode
contestants Shane Lewis broke three toes
while filming in Costa Rica according to
the New York Post however when the
episode aired in 2013 the audience only
learns that he injured his foot somehow
the severity of the injury isn't
disclosed which is a strange choice
given the nature of the show because if
I die nobody gives it poison producer
while Lewis's foot injury kind of got
swept under the rug
producers note the injury of one of
their own for all it's worth during
filming in Costa Rica one of the
producers suffered a bite from a
fer-de-lance one of the deadliest pit
Piper's on the planet and as I jumped
down I felt this barring I hit me on the
left foot I knew straight away that it
was a bite or a sting of some
description quick and irritable the
fer-de-lance venom can cause bleeding of
the gums and nose gastrointestinal
bleeding and vomiting among a slew of
other unpleasant symptoms in order to
save the producers foot doctors needed
to hack off a 5 by 12 inch section of
his flesh I spent a month in hospital in
total I had several surgical procedures
removing dead tissue having the skin
graft and then follow-up procedures on
that it's lucky that medical specialists
were there a little help
broken toes and poisonous snakes aside
contestants of naked and afraid don't
truly have much reason to be afraid
that's because they benefit from medical
attention behind the scenes as well in
the premiere episode hungry and
desperate contestant Kim Shelton killed
cooked and ate a poor defenseless turtle
as a result she became violently ill
throughout the following three days
Shelton was shown sleeping and suffering
yet on the fourth day she was feeling
much better how unbeknownst to viewers
medics nursed her back to health with
two IVs and some baby food now hopefully
no reality show will ever allow any of
its contestants to die for the sake of
ratings the producers of naked and
afraid are smart enough to have doctors
on set however disguising the fact that
medical attention is given to cast and
crew is still dishonest and potentially
dangerous for anyone who sees the show
and thinks roasted Beach turtle is a
good meal choice no clothes no problem
the people who appear on naked and
afraid like hanging out in the buff for
your viewing pleasure I like being naked
it's a good thing too considering the
nature of the show during a panel at the
TCA summer TV press tour contestant
Danny Julian said the naked aspect of
the show just adds another element to
the survival challenge however there was
one gripe that survivalists had with it
while contestants don't mind appearing
in their birthday suits some of them
wish the pixelation was handled
differently former contestant Justin
Bullard said they could have made my
blurr spot bigger
buck up little guy but even though
contestants are okay with showing some
skin some viewers are downright irate
about it 1 Million Moms the collective
of eternally disapproving individuals
that is 1 Million Moms objects to the
existence of naked and afraid but
considering this group finds problems
with just about everything that's not
much of a surprise the ordinary old
ladies have blasted the show referring
to it as offensive inappropriate and
soft porn according to the Christian
Post as part of their crusade against
bare bottoms they've taken to calling
show sponsors and asking them to stop
buying ads during the show it seems to
be working according to them they
managed to get both Delta Faucet and
Mars Inc to pull ads from not just the
show but the network as a whole during a
2016 marathon looks like 1 Million Moms
actually accomplished something which is
both surprising and frightening look out
Kermit they're coming for you next you
can't hack it it stands to reason that
not everyone who survives naked and
afraid would survive a similar yet
actually life and death situation during
a reddit AMA former season one
contestant for Escalante had some choice
words about Co contestant Cassie typical
according to him Depok alone Leigh
appeared on the show with the hope that
it would lead to fame and fortune since
it worked so well for survivors Richard
Hatch they should give Forrest a show
called naked and throwing shade thanks
for watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know what you've heard about
naked and afraid
[Music]